So my name is Amy Webb,
and a few years ago
I found myself at the end
of yet another fantastic relationship
that came burning down
in a spectacular fashion.
And I thought, what's wrong with me?
I don't understand
why this keeps happening.
So I asked everybody in my life
what they thought.
I turned to my grandmother,
who always had plenty of advice,
and she said, "Stop being so picky.
You've got to date around.
And most importantly,
true love will find you
when you least expect it."
Now as it turns out,
I'm somebody who thinks a lot about data,
as you'll soon find.
I am constantly swimming
in numbers, formulas and charts.
I also have a very tight-knit family,
and I'm very, very close with my sister,
and as a result, I wanted to have
the same type of family when I grew up.
So I'm at the end of this bad breakup,
I'm 30 years old,
I figure I'm probably going to have
to date somebody for about six months
before I'm ready to get monogamous
and before we can sort of cohabitate,
and we have to do that
for a while before we can get engaged.
And if I want to start having children
by the time I'm 35,
that meant that I would have
had to have been on my way to marriage
five years ago.
So that wasn't going to work.
If my strategy was to least-expect
my way into true love,
then the variable that I had
to deal with was serendipity.
In short, I was trying to figure out
what's the probability
of my finding Mr. Right?
Well, at the time I was living
in the city of Philadelphia,
and it's a big city, and I figured,
in this entire place,
there are lots of possibilities.
So again, I started doing some math.
Population of Philadelphia:
it has 1.5 million people.
I figure about half of that are men,
so that takes the number down to 750,000.
I'm looking for a guy
between the ages of 30 and 36,
which was only four percent
of the population,
so now I'm dealing
with the possibility of 30,000 men.
I was looking for somebody who was Jewish,
because I am and that was important to me.
That's only 2.3 percent of the population.
I figure I'm attracted to maybe
one out of 10 of those men,
and there was no way I was going to deal
with somebody who was an avid golfer.
So that basically meant
there were 35 men for me
that I could possibly date
in the entire city of Philadelphia.
In the meantime,
my very large Jewish family
was already all married
and well on their way
to having lots and lots of children,
and I felt like I was
under tremendous peer pressure
to get my life going already.
So I have two possible
strategies at this point
I'm sort of figuring out.
One, I can take my grandmother's advice
and sort of least-expect my way
into maybe bumping into the one
out of 35 possible men
in the entire 1.5-million-person
city of Philadelphia,
or I could try online dating.
Now, I like the idea of online dating,
because it's predicated on an algorithm,
and that's really just
a simple way of saying
I've got a problem,
I'm going to use some data,
run it through a system
and get to a solution.
So online dating is the second
most popular way
that people now meet each other,
but as it turns out,
algorithms have been around
for thousands of years
in almost every culture.
In fact, in Judaism,
there were matchmakers a long time ago,
and though they didn't have
an explicit algorithm per se,
they definitely were running
through formulas in their heads,
like, is the girl going to like the boy?
Are the families going to get along?
What's the rabbi going to say?
Are they going to start
having children right away?
The matchmaker would sort
of think through all of this,
put two people together,
and that would be the end of it.
So in my case, I thought,
well, will data and an algorithm
lead me to my Prince Charming?
So I decided to sign on.
Now, there was one small catch.
As I'm signing on to the various
dating websites,
as it happens, I was really, really busy.
But that actually
wasn't the biggest problem.
The biggest problem is that I hate
filling out questionnaires of any kind,
and I certainly don't like questionnaires
that are like Cosmo quizzes.
So I just copied
and pasted from my résumé.
(Laughter)
So in the descriptive part up top,
I said that I was
an award-winning journalist
and a future thinker.
When I was asked about fun activities
and my ideal date,
I said monetization
and fluency in Japanese.
I talked a lot about JavaScript.
(Laughter)
So obviously this was not the best way
to put my most sexy foot forward.
But the real failure was that
there were plenty of men for me to date.
These algorithms had a sea full of men
that wanted to take me out
on lots of dates --
what turned out to be truly awful dates.
There was this guy Steve, the I.T. guy.
The algorithm matched us up
because we share a love of gadgets,
we share a love of math
and data and '80s music,
and so I agreed to go out with him.
So Steve the I.T. guy invited me out
to one of Philadelphia's
white-table-cloth,
extremely expensive restaurants.
And we went in, and right off the bat,
our conversation really
wasn't taking flight,
but he was ordering a lot of food.
In fact, he didn't even bother
looking at the menu.
He was ordering multiple appetizers,
multiple entrées, for me as well,
and suddenly there are piles
and piles of food on our table,
also lots and lots of bottles of wine.
So we're nearing the end
of our conversation
and the end of dinner, and I've decided
Steve the I.T. guy and I are really
just not meant for each other,
but we'll part ways as friends,
when he gets up to go to the bathroom,
and in the meantime,
the bill comes to our table.
And listen, I'm a modern woman.
I am totally down with splitting the bill.
But then Steve the I.T. guy
didn't come back.
(Gasping)
And that was my entire month's rent.
(Audience gasps)
So needless to say,
I was not having a good night.
So I run home, I call
my mother, I call my sister,
and as I do, at the end of each one
of these terrible, terrible dates,
I regale them with the details.
And they say to me,
"Stop complaining."
(Laughter)
"You're just being too picky."
So I said, fine, from here on out
I'm only going on dates
where I know there's Wi-Fi,
and I'm bringing my laptop.
I'm going to shove it into my bag,
I'm going to have this email template,
and I'm going to fill it out
and collect information
on all these different
data points during the date
to prove to everybody that empirically,
these dates really are terrible.
(Laughter)
So I started tracking things like
really stupid, awkward, sexual remarks;
bad vocabulary;
the number of times a man
forced me to high-five him.
(Laughter)
So I started to crunch some numbers,
and that allowed me
to make some correlations.
So as it turns out,
for some reason, men who drink Scotch
reference kinky sex immediately.
(Laughter)
Well, it turns out
that these probably weren't bad guys.
There were just bad for me.
And as it happens, the algorithms
that were setting us up,
they weren't bad either.
These algorithms were doing exactly
what they were designed to do,
which was to take
our user-generated information,
in my case, my résumé,
and match it up
with other people's information.
See, the real problem here is that,
while the algorithms work just fine,
you and I don't,
when confronted with blank windows
where we're supposed to input
our information online.
Very few of us have the ability
to be totally and brutally
honest with ourselves.
The other problem
is that these websites are asking us
questions like, are you
a dog person or a cat person?
Do you like horror films or romance films?
I'm not looking for a pen pal.
I'm looking for a husband. Right?
So there's a certain amount
of superficiality in that data.
So I said fine, I've got a new plan.
I'm going to keep using
these online dating sites,
but I'm going to treat them as databases,
and rather than waiting
for an algorithm to set me up,
I think I'm going to try
reverse-engineering this entire system.
So knowing that there was superficial data
that was being used
to match me up with other people,
I decided instead to ask my own questions.
What was every single possible thing
that I could think of
that I was looking for in a mate?
So I started writing
and writing and writing,
and at the end, I had amassed
72 different data points.
I wanted somebody was Jew-ish,
so I was looking for somebody
who had the same background
and thoughts on our culture,
but wasn't going to force me to go to shul
every Friday and Saturday.
I wanted somebody who worked hard,
because work for me
is extremely important,
but not too hard.
For me, the hobbies that I have
are really just new work projects
that I've launched.
I also wanted somebody
who not only wanted two children,
but was going to have the same
attitude toward parenting that I do,
so somebody who was going
to be totally okay
with forcing our child to start
taking piano lessons at age three,
and also maybe computer science classes
if we could wrangle it.
So things like that,
but I also wanted somebody
who would go to far-flung,
exotic places, like Petra, Jordan.
I also wanted somebody who would weigh
20 pounds more than me at all times,
regardless of what I weighed.
(Laughter)
So I now have
these 72 different data points,
which, to be fair, is a lot.
So what I did was, I went through
and I prioritized that list.
I broke it into a top tier
and a second tier of points,
and I ranked everything starting at 100
and going all the way down to 91,
and listing things like I was looking
for somebody who was really smart,
who would challenge and stimulate me,
and balancing that with a second tier
and a second set of points.
These things were also important to me
but not necessarily deal-breakers.
(Laughter)
So once I had all this done,
I then built a scoring system,
because what I wanted to do
was to sort of mathematically calculate
whether or not I thought
the guy that I found online
would be a match with me.
I figured there would be
a minimum of 700 points
before I would agree to email somebody
or respond to an email message.
For 900 points,
I'd agree to go out on a date,
and I wouldn't even consider
any kind of relationship
before somebody had crossed
the 1,500 point threshold.
Well, as it turns out,
this worked pretty well.
So I go back online now.
I found Jewishdoc57
who's incredibly good-looking,
incredibly well-spoken,
he had hiked Mt. Fuji,
he had walked along the Great Wall.
He likes to travel
as long as it doesn't involve
a cruise ship.
And I thought,
I've done it!
I've cracked the code.
I have just found
the Jewish Prince Charming
of my family's dreams.
There was only one problem:
He didn't like me back.
And I guess the one variable
that I haven't considered
is the competition.
Who are all of the other women
on these dating sites?
I found SmileyGirl1978.
She said she was a "Fun girl
who is Happy and Outgoing."
She listed her job as "teacher."
She said she is
"silly, nice and friendly."
She likes to make people laugh "alot."
At this moment I knew,
clicking profile after profile
that looked like this,
that I needed to do some market research.
So I created 10 fake male profiles.
Now, before I lose all of you --
(Laughter) --
understand that I did this
strictly to gather data
about everybody else in the system.
I didn't carry on crazy Catfish-style
relationships with anybody.
I really was just scraping their data.
But I didn't want everybody's data.
I only wanted data on the women
who were going to be attracted
to the type of man that I really,
really wanted to marry.
When I released these men into the wild,
I did follow some rules.
So I didn't reach out to any woman first.
I just waited to see
who these profiles were going to attract,
and mainly what I was looking at
was two different data sets.
So I was looking at qualitative data,
so what was the humor, the tone,
the voice, the communication style
that these women shared in common?
And also quantitative data,
so what was the average length
of their profile,
how much time was spent between messages?
What I was trying to get at here was
that I figured, in person,
I would be just as competitive
as a SmileyGirl1978.
I wanted to figure out how to maximize
my own profile online.
Well, one month later,
I had a lot of data,
and I was able to do another analysis.
And as it turns out,
content matters a lot.
So smart people tend to write a lot --
3,000, 4,000, 5,000 words
about themselves,
which may all be very, very interesting.
The challenge here, though,
is that the popular men and women
are sticking to 97 words on average
that are written very, very well,
even though it may not seem
like it all the time.
The other hallmark
of the people who do this well
is that they're using
non-specific language.
So in my case,
"The English Patient"
is my most favorite movie ever,
but it doesn't work
to use that in a profile,
because that's a superficial data point,
and somebody may disagree
and decide they don't want to go out
because they didn't like
sitting through the three-hour movie.
Also, optimistic language matters a lot.
So this is a word cloud
highlighting the most popular
words that were used
by the most popular women,
words like "fun" and "girl" and "love."
And what I realized was not
that I had to dumb down my own profile.
Remember, I'm somebody who said
that I speak fluent Japanese
and I know JavaScript
and I was okay with that.
The difference is that it's about being
more approachable
and helping people understand
the best way to reach out to you.
And as it turns out, timing
is also really, really important.
Just because you have access
to somebody's mobile phone number
or their instant message account
and it's 2 o'clock in the morning
and you happen to be awake,
doesn't mean that that's a good time
to communicate with those people.
The popular women on these online sites
spend an average of 23 hours
in between each communication.
And that's what we would normally do
in the usual process of courtship.
And finally --
there were the photos.
All of the women who were popular
showed some skin.
They all looked really great,
which turned out to be in sharp contrast
to what I had uploaded.
(Laughter)
Once I had all of this information,
I was able to create a super profile,
so it was still me,
but it was me optimized now
for this ecosystem.
And as it turns out,
I did a really good job.
I was the most popular person online.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
And as it turns out, lots and lots
of men wanted to date me.
So I call my mom, I call my sister,
I call my grandmother.
I'm telling them about this fabulous news,
and they say, "This is wonderful!
How soon are you going out?"
I said, "Actually, I'm not going
to go out with anybody."
Because remember, in my scoring system,
they have to reach a minimum
threshold of 700 points,
and none of them have done that.
They said, "What?
You're still being too damn picky."
Well, not too long after that,
I found this guy, Thevenin,
and he said that he was culturally Jewish,
he said that his job
was an arctic baby seal hunter,
which I thought was very clever.
He talked in detail about travel.
He made a lot of really
interesting cultural references.
He looked and talked exactly
like what I wanted,
and immediately, he scored 850 points.
It was enough for a date.
Three weeks later, we met up in person
for what turned out to be
a 14-hour-long conversation
that went from coffee shop to restaurant
to another coffee shop
to another restaurant,
and when he dropped me back off
at my house that night
I re-scored him --
[1,050 points!]
Thought, you know what,
this entire time,
I haven't been picky enough.
Well, a year and a half after that,
we were non-cruise ship traveling
through Petra, Jordan,
when he got down on his knee and proposed.
A year after that, we were married,
and about a year and a half after that,
our daughter, Petra, was born.
Audience: Oh!
(Applause)
[What it means...]
Obviously, I'm having
a fabulous life, so --
(Laughter)
The question is, what does
all of this mean for you?
Well, as it turns out,
there is an algorithm for love.
It's just not the ones
that we're being presented with online.
In fact, it's something
that you write yourself.
So whether you're looking
for a husband or a wife
or you're trying to find your passion
or you're trying to start a business,
all you have to really do
is figure out your own framework
and play by your own rules,
and feel free to be as picky as you want.
Well, on my wedding day,
I had a conversation again
with my grandmother,
and she said, "All right,
maybe I was wrong.
It looks like you did come up
with a really, really great system.
Now, your matzah balls ...
They should be fluffy, not hard."
(Laughter)
And I'll take her advice on that.
(Applause)